we're doing this because we see from
consumers today a growing demand for
electrified vehicles what we're
announcing today is that any new car
line that we launched after 2019 will
have electrification and that will range
from full electrification a full battery
electric vehicle through to an assisted
internal combustion engine with either
plug-in hybrid or a mild hybrid
powertrain which is a battery assisted
internal combustion engine why customers
demanding this is this a reaction to the
Volkswagen emissions scandal do you
think our customers do want cleaner
cities and this is our way of providing
that consumer demand and what's the
price point going to be is this going to
be comparable to the current kind of
costs
well the pricing of course is yet to be
determined
and the range that we will launch will
have a variety of pricing pure electric
is likely to be at the top end of that
price point and at the lower end a mild
hybrid will be perhaps the more
affordable in that range so what do you
think the last internal combustion
engines will be powering cars on
Britain's roads then really that will be
driven by consumers it will be driven by
the speed at which people adopt these
new technologies the technologies that
we're leading the way with now and I
wouldn't like to pin a find data on that
but it's driven by the consumer but why
aren't you for example just looking at
cleaner forms of existing technology
like the internal combustion engine only
reducing carbon emissions from that why
do you have to go down this whole new
route of hybrids and electric vehicles
we've been doing that for some time of
course but this is taking us to the
ultimate solution of having an
emission-free vehicle what about
charging points for electric vehicles I
mean one his complaints already that
there aren't enough of them once
electric vehicles gain momentum and more
the population start to use them the
government's really going to have to get
behind this and local authorities and
stop
more than one Lee yeah the
infrastructure is going to have to
change charge points is part of it
but of course with a full battery
vehicle a lot of that charging will be
done at home or at the office so you
know domestically and and companies will
also have to look at the provision of
charge points for full electric vehicles
moving forward what do you think of them
personally do you enjoy driving them
compared with traditional petrol and
diesel engines I do you get a variety of
different driving styles obviously
there's the economy but also the
serenity of driving a full electric
vehicle is quite special plus
electrification doesn't rule out
performance you know an electric vehicle
can be quite an exhilarating drive also
so I I do enjoy the variety of driving
styles than an electrified vehicle
offers that is that your main car of
choice at the moment then I I have a
hybrid xc90 yes indeed